un quart de siècle après sa mort elvis
presley reste un formidable bus business
qui rapporte des millions de dollars ses
disques se vendent toujours autant il
sert de support à des gadgets en tout
genre que ses fans s'arrachent
voyez ce reportage à paris dans une
boutique entièrement dédiée aux kings
béatrice blondeau et patrice wucher donc
sa boutique parisienne
au rayon des gadgets la dernière
nouveauté c'est le téléphone elvis elvis
que vous retrouve sous forme d'horloge
de couper deux bouteilles de champagne
aussi en version on tasse à café
c'est chez les femmes c'est le chanteur
que l'on préfère retenir celui qui
révolutionna la musique en réconciliant
la connerie des blancs et le rythm n
blues dès - à mon époque on pouvait pas
écouter la musique on voulait être à
l'écouté la musique à papa et maman
il n'y avait rien il ya derrière cette
époque-là pondu par quand il vise à
arriver
c'était la révolution ce que je
préférais moi c'est la dernière période
où il était un petit peu plus fini avec
ses amis de seine et les grosses roues
flat y est
et puis en fait j'ai appris à la
découvrir le début les années 50 en fait
tout un plat
red bull aura réussi ce que personne
d'autre n'a fait avant lui donner un
visage et une voix au rêve américain à
vendre
c'est via kns assassine son vélo chez sa
voix de crooner ou inspirés de
génération aux vierges rocker il 25 ans
après c'est elvis là qu'il ait fait
toujours rage et c'était après la guerre
tout se reconstruit qui vous
reconstruisez le rêve était là et lui
représentait le rêve c'était un fils de
pauvres des pauvres gens le père avait
été plus ou moins en prison l'été
camionneurs et tout d'un coup il devient
monsieur musique monsieur rock n roll
c'est une sorte d'app autres quelque
part je pense que c'est pour ça qu'il
est oublié et inoubliable mais derrière
le rêve
il y a aussi le business plus d'un
milliard de disques vendus 37 millions
de dollars de retombées financières rien
que pour l'année dernière du dernier
film de walt disney aux chansons rares
est introuvable
elvis presley se vend bien et même très
bien
son dernier single un remix est numéro
un aux états unis
alors question le king est il vraiment
mort
pour les marchands souvenir le roi du
rock aura en tout cas toujours une
immense qualité celle de faire danser
les tiroirs caisses